[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
modernizing our roads our airports our
ports our waterways
tonight on politics now state of the
union the new agenda for president joe
biden after his address to congress and
the nation
we need a voucher program
that's republican gubernatorial
candidate joey gilbert who tells us his
plans for education and reworking
sentencing reform
i would imagine that that that's
you know
that's something that's going to be
discussed at the next session
will ccsd get broken up the chair of the
education committee tells us what he
expects in the legislature
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we start
though with an investigation by nevada
state police detectives are now looking
into verbal harassment against governor
steve sisilak the man responsible
recorded it all although we're not able
to show it to you here first on this
video the suspect told the governor he
should be strung up by a lamp post then
he made comments about first lady kathy
sisilak's asian heritage the man refused
to apologize
now governor siselak's campaign called
the abuse on camera racist says the
attacks are unbecoming behavior for
nevadans
while the more extreme right in nevada
republicans anyway stood behind the
suspect the maine nevada gop condemned
the verbal attack gubernatorial
candidate and sheriff joe lombardo well
he called the harmful rhetoric a
distraction he says the only recourse is
voting the governor out we'll continue
to watch this investigation
on tuesday president joe biden held his
first state of the union speech now he
and democrats on capitol hill they're
pushing the agenda for the year as bazel
john looks into how democrats are hoping
to make progress
fresh off outlining his agenda during
the state of the union president joe
biden started making his case to the
american people invest in america
educate the american people
grow the workforce at an event in
wisconsin the president emphasized how
his bipartisan infrastructure law is
creating jobs modernizing our roads our
airports our ports our waterways and in
north carolina vice president kamala
harris said the administration is
fighting for a better future our fight
starts with lowering the cost of living
for working families another item in the
president's speech was a call to expand
background checks and ban assault style
weapons my hope is that the president's
dedication this cause will give us
more momentum connecticut senators
richard blumenthal and chris murphy as
well as connecticut congresswoman rosa
delauro are ready to take steps to
reduce gun deaths step up
and pass meaningful legislation that
will reduce the rate of gun violence
it's about the health and safety of our
children while president biden called
for more funding for police to reduce
gun violence senator murphy says there
are other ways to address the problem
this administration
can do more but senate republican leader
mitch mcconnell says all the president's
plans are out of touch with the country
and will lead to trouble for democrats
at this year's november elections if
president biden does not correct course
sharply and quickly
the american people may correct the
course
for him reporting in washington i'm
basil john
joining us now to talk about the state
of the union alex limon from our
washington d.c bureau alex in the state
of the union speech president biden laid
out a lot of different aspects of his
agenda
what is the first part of what he
described earlier this week that he's
going to try and push through capitol
hill
well president biden talked a lot about
what he called his
unity agenda things that he believes
that he can get to pass through congress
with bipartisan support getting
democrats republicans and some of those
centrist moderates on board and he
pointed toward his bipartisan
infrastructure law that was passed by
congress as kind of a sign that he can
get this done and so he talked about
several things within that so-called
unity agenda things like fighting the
opioid epidemic
tackling the issue of children's mental
health which a lot of children's health
care experts and the american pediatrics
association said has reached crisis
levels because of both the pandemic and
the issue that social media really fuels
that problem especially when really
young kids and teens are you know
allowed to use it to a certain extent
it's just really not helpful so those
were things the president talked about a
number one issue for a lot of us these
days of course is inflation it touches
so many parts of our economy what's the
plan for the white house from the
president to try and deal with this
yeah president biden really tried to
make the point to the american people
that he understands what they're feeling
that he sort of grew up in in the type
of middle class family that felt that
pain whenever prices did rise and so he
tried to make that connection with
americans he also tried to
talk about what the administration is
trying to do for example releasing tens
of millions of barrels of oil from the
strategic national reserve and also
talked about how he has gotten allies to
do the same around the world but it's
it's tough to know whether that's really
going to make much of an impact on gas
prices for example at all because of the
crisis that we are seeing in ukraine and
russia which is obviously having the
opposite effect and driving those prices
up
the president also talked about for
example trying to tackle the higher
prices of goods by making more things in
america
nevada democrats serving in congress
applauded the president's speech
well for months here in politics now
we've been speaking with nevada's
gubernatorial candidates among the
republican challengers sheriff joe
lombardo has the fundraising lead
however he has not taken part in any of
the debates on the other hand former
boxer current attorney and president
trump supporter joey gilbert he's been
front and center i sat down with him
this week and we started with a topic
where he separates himself from the
other republican candidates sentencing
reform
speaking of criminal justice reform
sentencing guidelines have been have
been altered in the last legislative
session
let's talk about marijuana
penalties marijuana felony crimes would
you like to see lighter or stiffer
sentences specific to marijuana drug
crimes well you know i've taken some
heat in the in the previous couple
months because at one time i was
supporting attorney general aaron ford
when he was our majority leader in the
senate because we both agreed that we
needed to see some changes on marijuana
laws how can you have a recreational
state or adult use state and then try
and lock somebody up for an amount of
marijuana that you can fly across the
country with so we need to make sure
that people that are that have felonies
or convicted of those kinds of cases
years ago get that stain off their
record so they can have a chance to
compete you know for for jobs that have
you know good opportunities
has your
opinion of or your thoughts on dealing
with the issue of immigration
changed since you announced your
candidacy
i mean look at the end of the day we
want lawful legal immigration i think
that's
i don't think anybody's against that um
i am absolutely a hundred percent
against illegal immigration where
they're busing thousands of people in
from the border states and dumping them
here in clark county and up in northern
nevada that can't happen we don't have
the time or the resources or you know
this the the ability the sustainability
for folks like that so i'm against that
right now i think we need a complete
pause almost a moratorium on immigration
till we get the remaining mexico back in
place and get that wall finished the
environment um here in southern nevada
we have the issue with the water
dropping on the colorado and lake mead
up north there's issues with the
environment and all the wildfires that
there have been up there in recent years
um
let's talk specifically about the
colorado river
how would you as governor try to solve
the issue of the ongoing drought down
here in southern nevada well there's a
lot of things to do about the drought in
southern nevada number one we let
california take seven times their
allotment every year and no one does a
thing about it
another thing would be you know we're
looking at opportunities where we have
water that we're bringing in but we can
do better things in northern nevada with
irrigating more efficiently to save
water 70 of our water is spent
agriculture only 18 has been in uh
private use about seven percent has been
in the mines you know governor
sissellac's idea is to cut off all lawns
and whatnot in southern nevada and
that'll save less than a percent we got
to think outside the box and i mean
there's things we can do bringing in
water
i'd like to see desalination plants on
on the coast and pumping water back in
here but that's a whole different topic
but at the end of the day there are
things that we could do in the in the
central part of nevada with with cloud
seeding they're doing with desert
research institute so we can bring on
more water we've got to open all options
and we need to sit down with the leaders
in the north and people down here in the
south and come to come to an agreement
how do you
plan to tackle the issue of education if
you're elected governor
well look unless the public schools are
forced to compete with students they're
never going to get better so we need a
voucher program we need a voucher
program we need charter schools you know
school choice is the teachers union bait
and switch you know you're still stuck
in the same broken system we need a
complete overhaul the critical race
theory the transgender indoctrination
agenda stuff and again there's it's
that's scratching the surface you know
you look in whatever you want to look at
credit recovery you want to look at
restorative discipline these are things
that are not helping these kids and
again we're not just i'm not just saying
this we are 49th and 50th in the nation
for 10 years straight we've asked every
candidate for governor this question uh
here in clark county what are your
thoughts on the idea of splitting up
clark county schools absolutely it's too
big welcome stupid it's too big it's too
big and and local control there's no
reason that in mesquite and all these
other places where i've gone where they
say they're under ccsd that doesn't make
sense to me it needs to be split up
local control is the answer you were at
the rally
um
i was i was at a medical tyranny rally i
was not at the stop the steel rally but
i was in dc i was in our nation's
capital on january 6 very proud to been
there standing up for all rights for all
our constitutional rights and civil
liberties that were trampled on by all
these blue state governors and some red
state governors and so i was there
speaking against mass mandates lockdowns
the what i knew were the forthcoming uh
vaccine mandates which did come and have
been nothing but a complete disaster
have ruined the state and again the only
thing locked down slow slows the economy
we spoke about a lot of topics with mr
gilbert he also told us that he has
plans to reimagine the las vegas strip
but he wanted to save further details
for the general election you can watch
the full interview at 8newsnow.com
the number of active registered voters
in nevada is increasing more people are
registered now as nonpartisan secretary
of state's office says there were 11
thousand 700 new voters in february 9
200 of them registered as nonpartisan as
you see there
nonpartisan is the default answer at the
dmv but a lot of people are switching
their party affiliations more than 1400
voters are now registered as republican
856 as democrats of the new registered
voters
next on politics now we're going to talk
about breaking up clark county school
district
there's a lot of work that has to go
into that
state senator mo dennis chairs the
education committee we asked him about
the potential of carving up one of the
nation's biggest school districts plus
how the discussion about esports betting
centers around threats to the sport's
integrity
5.99 only a jack in the box
welcome back to politics now
calls to break up clark county school
district are growing a few weeks ago on
this program governor steve sisolak told
us he was in favor of at least the idea
all republican gubernatorial candidates
that we have asked are also in favor of
breaking it up several members of the
henderson city council are actively
trying to split clark county school
district now this has been discussed for
years back in 2015 there was a push in
the legislature to split up ccsd a bill
to make it into three parts passed and
was signed by then governor brian
sandoval something that would have had
to happen within three years but two
years later a separate bill passed that
measure kept ccsd intact but allowed for
more local control within the district
so will the new call for reforms see
more success i spoke with state senator
mo dennis he democrat is the chair of
the legislature's joint education
committee he says he expects this to
come up in the next session
something that we've been asking
all the candidates for governor about is
something that you're familiar with this
idea of breaking up clark county school
district
um as
long as i was in clark county school
district that's been something that
always gets brought up and then when it
gets to the legislative
uh chambers it just kind of
dissolves into something else
governors can gubernatorial candidates
say they're open to at least the idea of
it all of them seem to say that what do
you think about that idea
well i mean it's obvious i think that
the question should be what is it that
we need to do to make education better
for our kids if
if the current way that we're doing is
not working then we need to look for
other ways one of the things that we're
doing in the interim and i'm i as the
chair of the interim committee i'm
putting together a
task force
or i guess slash summit
on school governance
you know what the school board trustees
and how how do we administrate
um
and uh i think all
those are all things that we need to be
talking about how do we how do we uh put
the right governance in place to ensure
that we have student achievement and you
know with the with the with a new
funding plan
that focuses on the needs of an
individual student maybe i'm reading
between the lines here but it seems like
at least there's more willingness now
to
be open to that idea
in the past maybe you'll be shot down
right away is is that am i am i jumping
to too many of a conclusion there well i
i won't say that it's been shot down
right away in the past i think the you
know as a legislature we have 120 days
to to do something you know when we're
meeting session and a lot of times the
work hasn't been done in order to do
that kind of legislation
and so you know
a lot of the work that goes on in the
interim a lot of the work looking at
some of the studies that they've done
i think all of that has to happen um you
know for something like that to occur um
the there's a lot of work that has to go
into that and so making sure that that
the folks that are making proposals have
been able to get that work done so that
the discussion can really be had um
during that 120 days it's it's um you
know that's always been the challenge
and a lot of times it's not that people
they want to do something is that they
ran out of time do you think clark
county school district is too big
i in some respects i think they're
they're really big i think in other
respects i think that uh um you know i
always look at the funding um because
people say you can't throw money in
education but in the in the last few
years we've actually been putting more
money
into education and we've seen better
results than we've ever seen
a lot of times people complain about
stuff that happened in the past
you know something that was already
corrected
and and what we need to do is deal with
the issues that are before us today and
we know that if we put that funding into
programs at work that we're going to
have achievement and uh so i think that
we're putting together all the different
pieces that are going to help with that
and whether you know the district is too
big or not i think that um i think for
me if
i don't look at it
in that respect there are um
a lot of benefits obviously to being big
as far as purchasing
power
now supporters of splitting up ccsd
suggest it would among other things cut
down on administrative costs senator
dennis disputes that pointing out the
district already has the lowest
administrative costs in the country
we'll have more from senator dennis on
education coming up in later programs
next on politics now metro and ice up
next we'll take a closer look at how
gubernatorial candidate and sheriff joe
lombardo has handled immigration while
running metro police
and it could be the next frontier the
main concern for members of a new e's
sports commission this is 8 news now
news
now
you're watching politics now
often debated never really solved
immigration is frequently a topic here
in nevada several republican candidates
for governor have been heavily involved
in the immigration debate for years
former senator dean heller for example
who's running for governor he voted for
the so-called gang of eight immigration
bill when we spoke with him a few weeks
ago though his focus was on just clark
county sheriff joe lombardo's policies
the federal government when they had a
quarter of a million people coming over
the border said hey we gotta we gotta
ship these people somewhere and they
brought them to sanctuary cities so
clark county las vegas was getting all
these illegal immigrants uh bust in and
by the way they don't stay in clark
county when i'm in elko they ask me hey
why should we care if clark county is a
sanctuary city or not i said because
they don't stay in clark county they
take their gangs and they take their
drugs and they move them to washoe and
they move them to humboldt and they move
them to elko and the rest of the state
becomes full of gangs and and drug
problems and this is this is all on this
sheriff he turned this uh this uh county
into a sanctuary city and i will reverse
all of those policies including uh his
favorite policy of catch and release
sheriff lombardo quit using the ice
database with metro police that's called
287 g he did that after a federal court
ruling struck down the program heller
has attacked lombardo on that democrats
accused lombardo of turning over
everyone to immigration officials so we
asked the sheriff to clarify the policy
now we just present the information to
ice they make the evaluation through
their own resources and that information
that we provide to ice is people that
have been arrested for violent crime
to include domestic violence and dui
we did that in the past we're continuing
to do it we haven't gone into the
property type crime or the minor type
crime space
my intent is to present people that
intend to commit harm
separately the las vegas review journal
reported metro police are still
cooperating with ice officials and
sheriff lombardo acknowledged that in
our interview as well
republican senate candidate adam laxalt
meanwhile is opening a new campaign
office his latinos for laxalt office is
over at charleston and jones features
several latina women who are running for
office right now las vegas city
councilman victoria seaman and
congressional district one candidate
carolina serrano several former trump
campaign advisors were also on hand
former president trump campaign advisors
there's still a lot to figure out for
people before they can start betting on
esports this week a gaming control board
committee on esports held its first
meeting the members are trying to create
gambling rules for nevada the main
concern is integrity as it is with all
gaming one of those testifying ian smith
from the non-profit esports integrity
commission smith says 92 percent of
match fixing in esports is because of
betting fraud
where there is a market there are always
people trying to manipulate it so
the only question is whether they're
succeeding
smith the man at the top of your screen
there he lobbied for stronger
regulations to improve the wagering
landscape the new committee is going to
be meeting every quarter
500 million dollars it's a lot of money
and it's how much governor sisalak plans
to put towards affordable housing in
nevada he announced that investment in
the state of the state address but it is
important to know
what actually counts as affordable
housing homes for people who make less
than sixty percent of the average person
three hundred million dollars is going
to be put into a thousand new affordable
housing units across the state 130
million dollars will go towards
rehabbing about three thousand units
already affordable
the rest will go to buying land and
putting more houses on an incentive
program to drop the cost of new houses
a lot of work
next time for the hot seat coming up on
politics now the influential senators
that supreme court nominee katangi brown
jackson is meeting with and when our
confirmation hearings will start
cash in addition to all public offers
you're watching politics now
supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson is meeting with lawmakers in
washington d.c ahead of her confirmation
hearings here you can see that she's
meeting there with republican senators
that's chuck grassley ben sasse also she
met with and also she met with senate
judiciary chair dick durbin as well her
confirmation hearings are scheduled for
march 21st to the 24th typically the
most contentious part is during the
questioning that will be on days two and
day three
this week in what to watch candidates
filing for office the filing period for
non-judicial races starts in nevada on
monday and it runs until march 18th
candidates basically have 10 days to
officially declare for an office so
we're going to watch to see if there's
any last-minute editions and see if all
the candidates are going to stick in the
republican gubernatorial primary or
possibly switch to some other seats
could be a very interesting week thank
you for watching politics now we'll be
back with you next week
[Music]
you